i would like you
as a talk show host
to introduce our next guest
okay great he played the coleslaw king
of the world and josie's brother rob
take a look
i am josie geller high school student
senior class 1999.
uh-uh
you're kidding right what josie do you
remember high school
it was a long time ago do you remember
what they called you in high school
josie grossie
please welcome david
[Applause]
this i feel like i'm being punked
[Laughter]
i was told we were all gonna be wearing
costumes oh my god
i love it and i want to say that david
and i have had
a really long history um we grew up in
the same neighborhood right down the
street from each other what was it like
to know each other be friends and then
get to play
brother and sister together
yeah um it was it was a dream come true
i mean you put this beautiful film
together that was so heartfelt and has
stood the test of time
and now you're here and you're doing
your show and
and i'm so glad that like you get to see
how much the world loves you because i
love you and the world loves you
i have loved you my whole life david you
know one of the scenes that i think um
really resonated with people was having
rob tell josie
which we all needed to hear at some
point in our life you can't be held back
anymore by your own personal
insecurities
and that's where the famous line comes
in
i'm not joking
anymore
and that's attributed because we need
someone to see the thing that we cannot
see us
for ourselves
[Music]
you